as a london-based Imam and a community
activist I often find more Islam in
Britain than most Muslim countries Islam
is all about love and tolerance peace
and justice hospitality and charity are
these also not British values Islam is
supposed to be about freedom with honor
and dignity most Muslim countries do not
offer such freedom but in Britain we do
we have offered people safe and secure
home opportunities to excel in education
and wealth creation as well as live in a
tolerant society the purpose of Islam is
to offer protection to life intellect
property family and faith of all people
every citizen in Britain is guaranteed
all these and it is enshrined in law
this is what makes Britain more Islamic
than most Muslim countries fairness and
justice is equated to godliness in Islam
and these play the most important
feature of British way of life - the
truth is I don't find fairness and
justice in most Muslim countries
including Bangladesh Pakistan Egypt and
the Middle East in Britain today
everyone is equal in the eyes of the law
and this is so Islamic when I read the
Koran I find striving for excellence a
constant reminder and striving for
excellence is the basis of progress here
in the UK - where in the world can I
excel most today Britain of course I can
enjoy the freedom to explore and excel
in any career or profession have a think
about that the next time they tell you
we are all terrorists
you